in the meantime there there are now
multiple reports which is why i'm ready
to bring it to you multiple reports that
russia has bombed
kindergartens and orphanages in ukraine
potentially committing war crimes
there's a report from ilya lozovsky a
writer and senior editor for the
organized crime and corruption reporting
project who tweeted
quote reports that a ukrainian
kindergarten used as a shelter was hit
i will not share the images as they are
too graphic absent and extremely
compelling explanation hard to imagine
what it could be
this is a war crime this was later
apparently corroborated by dimitro
culeba the minister of foreign affairs
of ukraine who tweeted quote today's
russian attacks on kindergartens and
orphanages are war crimes and violations
of the rome statute together with the
office of the attorney general we are
collecting these and other materials
which we will immediately transfer to
the hague
responsibility is inevitable now we
can't dismiss and the reason i keep
saying this is because this
it has happened already
we can't dismiss the possibility
that someone is mistaken here
or that this is somehow not as reported
but there are now
multiple reports and corroborations even
from ukrainian state officials that
there have been bombings of
kindergartens and orphanages and of
course
you know
all of the bombing is wrong that's going
on here the sovereignty of ukrainian
borders is being violated this is a this
is
aggressive
action from putin all of those things
are true
in addition if indeed there are bombings
of kindergartens and orphanages taking
place then it makes it all the more
horrifying and it will likely take no
matter how how much longer this all goes
on and it could be two days it could be
two weeks it could be two months
probably not more than two months at
this at this level of escalation would
be my guess no matter how long it takes
much like with the trump administration
where it will take years to unwind
everything that happened
uh it will likely take
a long time to find out everything that
has taken place over the last week in
ukraine
let me know where your mind is on what
you expect to see over the next few days
here um find me on twitter at dpakman
let me know we'll take a quick break